[Music]
hello and welcome to drive with the DW
car show coming up a monster of a pickup
the toyota hilux a cute but slick city
runabout the renault twingo
plus the all-new Mazda cx-5
[Music]
Jimbo Gaeta is a Japanese phrase meaning
the unity of horse and rider and Mazdas
using the slogan to promote the new cx-5
the developers aim to ensure a response
to the driver rather than vice versa
Ronni lipstick wants to see whether he
can become one for the speedy steed
mazda has been riding high in europe
recently the car maker has seen sales on
the continent increase by 60% since 2012
and the cx-5 compact SUV has accounted
for a major part of that growth its
lightweight construction efficiency and
an attractive look are among the
principal factors for its success
looking to build on those strengths
mazda has enhanced the model after just
five years as with all modern cars as
Ronnie the cx-5 boasts a plethora of
sensors to monitor events and conditions
on the road and to a degree forecast
them too it comes with predictive
all-wheel drive should you even need
all-wheel drive we tested the
top-of-the-line sports edition of the
cx-5 which in Germany sells for just
under 35,000 euros
the engines are familiar there's a
choice of one 2.2 litre diesel and 2
naturally aspirated gasoline engines
with capacities of 2 and 2.5 liters
transmission is either stick or
automatic both with 6 speeds the visual
upgrade isn't immediately obvious as the
styling between the old and new versions
fairly differs apart from the 2
centimetres lost in height the Mazda
cx-5 s dimensions have changed only in
terms of millimeters the length and
width are practically identical a closer
look reveals that the 8 pillars have
been shifted back by four point three
centimeters which increases the distance
to the front axle and stretches the cars
proportions
the rear doors open up to 90 degrees to
make access easier for both human and
non-human cargo although it doesn't make
much sense in tight parking spaces but
what you're sitting inside the gym
beauty principle applies again rear
passengers now have the option of
connecting with the cx-5 literally as
hidden underneath the armrests are two
USB ports one for each occupant you can
also activate the seat heating for the
rear seats which was previously not
possible in the cx-5 Mazda has
completely redesigned the front cabin
the driver operates the sat-nav and
radio as usual by a knob on the center
console that dark finishes contrast with
a white leather upholstery of the sports
equipment line
those does Austin according to Feng
shooey rearranging furniture increases
the Qi flow and therefore your
well-being
Rani has never believed in that stuff
but there is something to Gymboree Thai
and it works in the cx-5 you know what
the car wants to do and the car can
predict what you want to do if the cx-5
has become a real all-rounder that can
be recommended for every target group
[Music]
yes - Taizo
contest arena's pay tree says she's
trying out the third generation Renault
Twingo this engine is no longer here but
here instead
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
inna says it now comes with a six-speed
dual-clutch transmission which is
unusual for runabouts like this so
she'll give it a try
Renault is only offering fuel-efficient
three cylinder engines with a capacity
of just one or zero point nine litres
for this car the power is sent to the
rear wheels eNOS is testing the SCE 70e
DC with 51 kilowatts of power it
treach's from 0 to 100 kilometers an
hour in 14.5 seconds reaching a top
speed of 155 eNOS says that even with
the smallest engine accelerating is good
fun she says the dual clutch
transmission lets it accelerate smoothly
and fast
this Twingo is 3 meters 59 long that's
10 centimeters shorter than its
predecessor it's wheels are closer to
the vehicle's corners which extended the
wheelbase by 13 centimeters it's only
available as a five-door model
the rear handles are hidden away in the
design
[Music]
and of course the rear mounted engine
has been insulated and covered when you
fold down the back seats you get a flat
cargo surface yes explain of this Twingo
with dual clutch transmission comes only
with the intense high-end equipment line
she really likes the materials and finds
that the buttons are kept to a minimum
that underscores her feeling that this
Twingo is very easy to drive and simple
to operate the cruise control for
example is located beside the gearshift
and regulated with buttons on the
steering wheel that Twingo also has an
eco mode it shifts gears swiftly to help
save fuel that also keeps the noise down
because the engine gets loud in the high
rev range
and this little box can be placed in the
cupholders useful for stowing things
the turning circle of 8.6 meters makes
the Twingo pretty agile so while other
cars take lots of cranking to make sharp
turns this compact can do it in a flash
but how does the tiny Twingo fare on the
highway
woodie's penis doesn't expect the Twingo
to excel but once you've gotten it up to
speed and found your spot it's alright
but eNOS wouldn't recommend any tricky
passing maneuvers the 1-liter 3-cylinder
engine doesn't offer much extra thrust
and high speeds speaking of which it's
time for another test
hey Yong
[Music]
enos calls down the guys she needs their
help the Twingo is great for one person
to get around town but what if you want
to take along a few passengers just
getting in is already a problem you've
got the duck and your knees will be up
against the front seats
[Music]
eNOS wants to know how they're doing in
the back she realizes it's pretty
cramped she asked them to stick it out
now the car is fall she wants to test
the engine he says she's gonna give it a
try
inna says that when the Twingo is fully
occupied and you're accelerating you can
really tell you hit the gas and it
shifts gear but takes a while to pick up
speed inna says it's certainly possible
to ride around with some buddies but you
won't be quite as fast
[Music]
she thinks the Renault Twingo is a
feisty city car but on long rides
it'll be cramped for for adults she
thinks the Twingo makes for a good
family car the dual clutch transmission
version can also be had with an engine
15 kilowatts more powerful eNOS would go
for that one dismiss outside
[Music]
the sports Therese Moe sees Porsha
launching its first station wagon and
it's some debut it makes the dash to 100
km/h and 4.6 seconds top speed is 275
km/h the trunk has a capacity of 425
litres with the seats up and 1295 litres
when folded down mercedes has given the
s-class a new facelift the front of the
flagship model has been lightly reworked
while the radiator grille and bumpers
are new the taillights likewise have a
new design featuring a new crystal
treatment the lower section of the rear
bumper has been slightly modified prices
and Germany start at around 85 thousand
euros
[Music]
be afraid be very afraid that black
badge models are the dark side of
rolls-royce dark direct and powerful
spawned by the makers own tuning
attempts to balance individual luxury
and outright bombast Chester I know
that's what more could a modern man or
woman want than health wealth and
coolness
so the sensible super-rich don't buy
just any rolls-royce they plumped for
the black batch the bad boy among
British luxury cars even the Emily
statuette is black there's a black
grille and lots of carbon and black
tailpipe finishers and Rolls Royces are
known for being palaces on wheels but
the black badge version seems more like
a rugged fortress in the Scottish
Highlands
but rolls wasn't content just to paint
everything black they've also been at
work on the engine and transmission
after all that's what tuning is all
about
[Music]
aside from the smart carbon-fiber
composite rims the profile hasn't
changed on request the chrome window
frames can be blackened too at a total
length of 5 meters 28 this mobile castle
weighs in at a hefty 2440 kilograms
trunk capacity is 470 liters
[Music]
come on father carbon-fiber replaces
wood trim aluminum house chrome and
matte black dominates the interior
inside the instrument panel is striking
seal with six layers of clear varnish
hand polished to a fine gloss after
being left to dry for a full 72 hours
[Music]
as soon as he starts off Reinhold census
that the steering is more direct and the
dampers are firmer iStent at 465
kilowatts the writhe black badge is the
most potent roles to date with its power
further enhanced by its 870 Newton
metres of torque fuel consumption is
rated at fourteen point six liters per
100 kilometers it accelerates from 0 to
100 km/h and 4.5 seconds
the stupid I know discovers the jerks
typical of fast starts and stops are
absent the low setting directs the
automatic transmission to start shifting
only after the engine reaches 6000 revs
on the gas pedal responds more
spontaneously so that two and a half
tons are pretty nimble but always a
rolls-royce just as a weightlifter is
not the ideal gymnast a rules limo can
hardly double as a sports car the
standards of self-assured elegance
combined with uncompromising luxury are
defining for the brand so the suspension
can only get so stiff and the exhaust
only so loud but there's a good reason
to dress the right in black with an
average age of 46 today's rules buyers
aren't the youngest and they tend to
want a chauffeur the best way to appeal
to a younger target group is with a
sporty ER model that reflects their
lifestyle
the Rolls Royces darker side has its
powers of Attraction a black badge marks
its owner as a cutting edge style
conscious and individualistic person but
anyone who spends over 300,000 euros on
a car has never been normal
maybe exceptional is the best
description
a robust look and chunky proportions the
unmistakable Toyota Hilux
typical Dodge Ram buyers would be all
over this pickup word not for the engine
but more on that later
the Hilux offers an extremely high
seating position and impressive ground
clearance the all-wheel version even
boasts off-road credentials
[Music]
our car test three manual says the
toyota hilux has a long tradition it's
been in production since 1968 and is now
in its eighth generation over 18 million
units were sold since it was first
introduced but unlike the Dodge Ram the
Hilux isn't available with a roaring v8
to suit its look our test car has a 2.4
liter diesel engine with 110 kilowatts
of power it goes from 0 to 100 km/h in
13 seconds and has a top speed of 170
the hilux has a wheelbase of over 3
meters that's half a meter longer than
the total length of a smart car plus
it's 1 point 8 meter height makes it one
of the tallest contenders around the
plastic fender liners are optional for
protecting the bodywork from scratches
the rear chrome bars are only available
with the invincible package
a trailer hitch is optional it can pull
a load of 3.2 tonnes
the NA deflation a man who loves the bed
it's got room for one thousand one
hundred kilos of cargo anything will fit
but it could get wet in the rain unless
you invest two thousand one hundred
euros for our top hot top that's costed
about 5,000 I know not always so you
might want to use a tarp he says you
could even take a nap in the back
machine gun safe Hilux is five point
three meters long and all three
available body versions the single cab
has a single row of seats while the
extra cab has an extra seating growth
but with little space the double cab
like our test card comes with plenty of
space in the back
the high Lexus interior is stripped down
but you won't have to do without sat-nav
yeah I look well the high looks is a
utility vehicle says he minor well you
don't get that feeling from the interior
because Toyota has made these synthetic
materials here and here look like
leather the surface even has mock
stitching it's not actual leather it's a
single piece of plastic it's cheap to
produce and resistant to scratches on
the light a 7-inch touchscreen is
standard fitted in the second equipment
line Duty comfort and upwards the Hilux
is much more than a utility vehicle it
also performs well on normal roads an
entry-level Hilux single cab can be had
for twenty-five thousand euros in
Germany
[Music]
pick up Seth Emanuel says pickups are
growing in popularity in Germany and
elsewhere and the Toyota Hilux has a
long tradition to look back on which is
an advantage
it means Toyota can sell a tried and
tested product in large numbers a double
cab edition of the Toyota Hilux will set
you back thirty-nine thousand five
hundred euros
[Music]
once every four years the quiet german
town of hess ish olden door becomes the
temporary heart of the volkswagen world
in june over 45,000 VW fans again
descended on the place for the 2017
edition of the international vintage
Volkswagens show hosted by its
initiative's christian women and his
father 12 gone as 12 God explains it all
started in 1994 with a crazy idea of his
son and his friend Bjorn they invited
Volkswagen to Hesse sholden door while
God suggests that they get better
organized but eventually got involved
himself it was such a hit that many
people said they'd like to come again so
they held the next show two years later
the first show had 68 cars the second
two hundred eighty and now it's got over
900 yet them about you got out there for
a few days
SH old indoors picturesque old town is
clogged with classic pre-1968 VW's with
streets devoted to specific models from
the beetle to the VW Transporter and
Karmann Ghia
while God is proud to report that they
have cars from 28 nations and visitors
from 49 countries this year was a record
with four cars setting out for Hesse
sholden d'Or from Malaysia three months
beforehand that shows just how big the
VW family is at the world's largest
vintage VW meet the people's car lives
up to its name
bringing fans together from all over the
world a Scottish bagpipes player
welcomes the Malaysian marathon drivers
about 22,000 plus kilometer
here he was simply
if anyone who drives an ampoule and said
they didn't have a breakdown yes there
is always be really fix-it along the way
we still reach all the destination on
time and I never miss a shadow yeah
we're the Malaysian Adventures a sense
of honor requires them to drive their VW
all the way back to a no doubt make lots
of more friends along the way
it's a big family of Volkswagen when I
travel with damn this I actually
experience how the car maker itself has
set up a special exhibition to provide
an in-depth look at the company's long
history parked next to the world's
oldest surviving beetle our unique
reproductions of long-lost prototypes on
today is hornik technical director of
VW's classic car collection back at
headquarters in Wolfsburg he gives us
the lowdown these are four magnificent
vehicles for the enthusiasts here that
represent the birth of the beetle
starting with a 1936 of e3 a prototype
followed a year later by the V 30 with
lots of modifications also on show the
world's oldest beetle the 3803 it was
the third car to be built in 1938 and
the first to go into post-war production
it was known as the CCG be the VW Beetle
conceived and designed in the 1930s over
20 1.5 million had come off the
production line by the time it was
phased out in 2003 it is without a doubt
the preeminent car of the 20th century
doesn't know anyone who doesn't have
some relative who's driven of oak swag
and he says Volkswagen is a link between
people there are no complexes everyone
helps everyone else oddly as Hornitos
how the entire town gears up for the
show every four years the shop windows
are all decorated with Volkswagen
paraphernalia while the streets are car
themed
and as everybody knows a Volkswagen runs
forever
[Music]
and on a rally through local hills the
village VW's encounter a rare amphibious
relative VW's type 166 has no need of a
ferry to cross the river
this driver explains it's part beetle
part Porsche
it does up to 73 km/h it was built from
1941 to 1943 and is awesome to drive on
the water
the schwimmwagen does an impressive 10
kilometers per hour not many of the
14,000 built have survived
it's something completely new for the
Malaysian VW fans campgrounds have been
laid out for the fans all around has
this old and Dorff and the multinational
atmosphere is very relaxed the
International vintage show is like a
Woodstock of VW devotees
[Music]
this is this couple from Germany might
not understand what everyone's saying
but they understand what they mean what
I really like about folks is the
community you can go around talk about
folks is also cool and this visitor from
Belgium finds Friends of every
nationality yeah it's a long trip but I
think it's worth it it's a really nice
place to be and it's a good atmosphere
and everybody's happy I think it's
perfect the way it is it's a Volkswagen
festival and it's worldwide
well no Schmidt confirms that what
they've seen so far tops everything the
organization is wonderful thanks to the
30 volunteers who've made the event
another resounding success
next time I Drive it howdy bumps up the
performance with a new rs5 and the BMW
530i
[Music]
[Music]